ma ragazzuoli benvenuto questo video
sono parigi registra in un episodio di
api prima di qui c'è ragazzi volevo
dirvi che ho appena finito di montare il
video che state per vedere si vede dalla
mia bellezza sì ho visto ragazzi che il
video dura circa una roba quasi tipo 20
minuti quindi na na na roba enorme o
dividerò quindi in due parti ragazzi
questo video la prima parte che vedrete
oggi è la seconda parte lo metterò
domenica quando esce più il normalmente
quindi questa domenica ci sarà seconda
parte di questo video niente ragazzi vi
lascio al video spero che vi piaccia
evviva il tè alla pesca ma lasciamo
perdere partiamo un colpito il ragazzo o
lasci sono faringei cazzo
calmati sparando con l'audio mille
fantasma vi saranno esplosi i timpani
all'inizio del video forte segue per
quello c'è una soluzione in realtà io
questo qua queste cose non sono cuffie
per ascoltare sono cuffie che riparano
dalla mia stessa voce cene se io questa
roba qua non mi sento e non mi do
fastidio cioè questo c'è questo
l'utilità di questa roba anche ragazzi
cominciano che nei primi perché anche io
ragazzi ogni tanto le mie esigenze
videoludiche che voglio fare una cosa
assolutamente come le donne quando
c'hanno alle mestruazioni bisogna fare
non so cosa devo fare ma ho vinto va
bene volta dal dottor ragazzi primarie
di secondo livello non so più contare
senti ebbe black keys molecola toe non
so perché è proceduto no cosa
[Musica]
the challenge cosa stare la sfida
ospitate che non soltanto è bello
ragazzi ho vinto è vinto tu pensi che io
abbia perso melata è stata una vittoria
talmente rapida che ho vinto non te ne
sei solo accorto sarò io ecco che era
cosa cazzo stavo facendo qualcuno ha
delle spiegazioni logiche per quello che
era appena successo in realtà ragazzi il
muro è finto pro però riesco ad
aggrapparmi in tempo a chiamare 9 è
difficile però è riuscire a e invece no
insomma
questo credo sia record del mondo spero
acceleri amico mio ho già provato a
challenge della graf armi amore visibile
non c'è niente che non sappia fare
tranne questo per un secondo ragazzi
sono rimasto qui soprano ecco sì oddio
oddio fermi fermi dondolati lurido dando
l'addio non si sa cosa è successo che va
bene questo è frutto di anni di gioco a
depp rivisto perché se non ci avrei mai
fatto ha soffiato che in you win amico
mio ho già fatto l'impossibile in tempo
già fatto l'impossibile in due minuti di
gioco quindi nomi
roma oggi che cazzata oltre al softball
trovo perfetto questo di canoa fermi di
cava bolchi è cascato bolchi e kick nome
ti ha dato tua madre ti prego perché
vomiti arcobaleni zio perché sto
lanciando dei meme a noi in billy billy
annoiato e che cosa amici a quello
sarebbe billy in realtà si chiama uk
prova scritta ingannati uno scoppio mi
farei uno scopo
se uno scopo da un millimetro sta
minchia che ci riesci a sto anch'io
vabbè lasciamo perdere non scopre
vinciamo perché se no comment non forget
to race ragazzi non dimenticatevi
lasciare mi piace il video c'è scritto
lì e non importa basta che got that
nukem ma e steve che sta affogando state
una cena nuke fatemi capire sei morto
che il pogo di steve potesse raggiungere
tale disastro perfetto aironi peperoni
reims questo è amico mio sarebbero dei
di peperoni
l'importante è vincere ragazzi ancora
non ci sei
come non detto vado avanti finché non
raggiungo jump secolo
e invece no ma che sfiga ecco l'effetto
è quello sarebbe un jump square frate
questo è un james carr fondo cazzo come
ci arrivo da una [ __ ] ma che cazzo
erano [ __ ] al rising legge per
carino e vabbè dai faceva una roma un po
più invece che disti livelli che tanto
non c'è verso skip intro non c'è una
intro skype
salve c'è un ghigno di una ghigliottina
sulla crisi
qualche ultima parola codardo sì mi
piace la corsa no questa è rising
leggendo skipper ho la testa non mi
serve grazie però perché ne apprezzo il
dono da chi fa più ridere che il boia le
all star il boia con le converse mi
mancava ragazzi dunque l'ambientazione
skyrim
c'è questo è un dato di fatto dal figlio
della [ __ ] cioè mi scrivete ragazzi
qual è il senso di solide ok giannino
anche dimenticato di essere morto così
mi ha risucchiato un pozzo ragazzi josè
sta roba the ring twitch la pittrice non
a queste youtube amico mio youtube la
piaga dei ratti è questo appello quello
sarebbe un ratto nei boschi di uccidere
la dr
intanto sono più bravo io
[Musica]
o velho schivato oddio
sono salvo sono vivo sono vivo per
miracolo la rising legend di cui parla a
livello sarà io c'è un piccolo le
ragazze mi manca siamo passati da skyrim
minecraft in un secondo gesù sei tu
le leggende erano vere non so gesù tu
sei quello scelto è grazie gesù sono ho
bisogno di uccidere ksera per salvarci
tutti ex era nascosta gesù la parte che
più che gesù sembrano uno shock che con
la tuta da maniaco è quello sarebbe xera
sembra un pokémon non mi sembra e è
morto gesù l'hai visto passare l'ho
ucciso vinte ecco è morto li vedi come è
gesù è infatti mi sta seguendo creva
addio è vacci piano che non c'è già non
so le braccia almeno il cuore lasciano
la fila [ __ ] che cazzo ci sono di
nuovo ragazzi devo uccidere si stronzi
prima che ammazzi nome ecco perfetto su
caso di the folletti della minkia
togliete e vi va bene che non ho la
palla da bowling sono giocavamo questo
ex era max herat non è uno di league of
leon a ecco infatti league of legends mi
sembrava strano 61 stato io preferisco
cynthia
addio ai miei staccato una gamba ma non
mi fermerò così oddio quanto stupida fa
va da 1 a rocco siffredi non lo so e
chiedo a dio
io sono vivo sono io per me è la tua
ultima a tutti spero vivamente nella
puntata e bassa fantastico this way this
was a level buy e main ctv bibò built on
amico mio che cazzo di nome ti sei fatto
lasciamo perdere
grazie comunque per avermi fatto
sconfiggere ksera e non era neanche
fidato 30 ragazzi facciamo questo che
ancora non ho fatto questo che deve
lanciare a eco sembrava strano parte che
non mi non li so giocare filtro faccio
pagare la spruzzo e invece try to stop
hard cos'è oddio devo fermarmi a devo
fermarmi prima di morire fantastico non
ho mai provato libro genova e vabbè era
impossibile l'avvocato di fermo invece è
invece 8 invece un pene come faccio a
impossibile perché va beh non sai come
almeno quello
oddio
ma vaffan cuore
ok dovevo fermarmi prima di ok come non
detto
quindi ragatzu ali questa è la vita di
oggi di aprire all scusate se non ho
fatto i miei livelli
li ho fatti nel altro episodio perché
non pensavo uscisse così lungo non
pensavo che uscisse così lungo è una
frase che non ripeterò mai più nella mia
vita per i ragazzi spero che vi sia
piaciuto e cosa mi è piaciuto commento è
non mi piace anche la pagina di facebook
come nei video trovate in description
senza vestiti scarpe ci picchiavano
costruito da ragazzi